hey welcome back to our channel my name
is samuel i'm amanda
and this is the samuel and amanda show
so
where we talk about money marriage life
and no one better to talk about that
than you amanda
okay because you know super killing it
what you've been up to this week
this week's been a fun week um we had
family over so
our kids reunited with our nieces and
nephews so that was really really nice
and we also reintroduced the bear to the
kids and we did
instagram actually and they love the
bear now
if anyone doesn't know is a humongous
bear outfit
that i thought would be a nice idea that
the kids would love but actually it
scared the
living daylights out of them
so now they have become friends with the
bear yes that's really good so did that
and just sorting bits out for my new car
which i will reveal which electric car i
went for
tesla is it a audi is it a merc
in fact i actually don't even know for
sure but um that's exciting
yeah so that's what i've been up to what
about you um well yeah i mean
um it's been a real family it's been a
real family week actually hasn't it yeah
so we
yesterday went out for lunch oh
beautiful night i don't even know where
it was where was that place
it was in a place called sturk stoke
podges i think that's how you pronounce
it but the hotel was called
anyway it was amazing um so i had a
lovely lunch there with some family
and in really exciting news is that your
parents
are moving to the area which is fabulous
so basically we moved
to beckons field buckinghamshire a
couple years ago
and russell anna came and now
then your brother came yeah to work on
the business and your brother and wife
yeah so it's like we're trying to
like bring everybody over this way now
your parents are moving yeah so
they've agreed to move but i'm trying to
make sure that it's totally sealed so
i'm currently trying to find them a
house
to live in and then and then um and then
yeah at the moment your mom's living
with us
for the for the short term yeah while we
find them a house and then dad's gonna
come down so
yeah that's really exciting we viewed a
couple houses today they both we did
we're terrible oh my gosh i couldn't
believe the parking on one of them
the person who built those houses
clearly got they got the planning
to build the houses but i mean in terms
of the road layout when you're
when you're viewing properties as a
property developer and investor you kind
of
have a different a different expectation
on properties
okay so last week we talked about how
disappointed we were with the lack of
questions from you guys and as a result
we had
loads and loads of really really good
really really good questions
so i'm going to read out some of the
questions from you and while i'm asking
while we're going through these
questions if you've got a question for
me or for amanda if it's about money
marriage or life go ahead comment your
question below
and we'll do our best to answer next
week so
okay this is what asabi
asake i hope i pronounced that right
said
yeah um love you guys could you do a
video on the top
things you've learned from being married
in general and things that being married
has taught you about yourselves
and about each other um
so go on you go first top things that
we've learned together as a couple or
me okay whatever um what you've learned
well that you have to really be selfless
and
put the other person first um so
yeah just not being selfish so
i'm trying to think yeah it's easier
when you're a team when you're a two
if you think about the other person's
needs yeah and let them think about your
needs
rather than you yeah you never clash
then because you're both thinking of
each other
yeah so i think that and then also just
communication as well
being a really really big thing just
always communicating how you feel
so you're on the same page not just in i
think that you asked about business as
well but it's the same in business i
think communication
um is really really important if
something is um
bothering you like what about the other
day when you said to me about the
the the bed sheets oh yeah
tell them tell them what samuel loves to
have a little lie on the bed in the
afternoon
when i wake up in the morning i make the
beds straight away and i like it to stay
like that
she makes it like immaculate it's like
making it to the point where it looks
like
uh you're at a hotel and it's just
wrapped up with the all the
pillows that we don't need what is the
point
what is the point of these
pillows please tell me oh my goodness do
you ever
ever sleep on these pillows it looks
nice so i dress the bed and i make it
look really nice
he comes up in the middle of the day has
a like she'll be upset about that right
now
and then i know that's really bad i'll
have to pick up the pillow after that
after the filming finishes and i'll have
to put it back in the perfect spot
yeah and then when i come up to bed at
night i like to come up and then it
should be just
ah nice and then you get into bed and
then you feel good but when i come
upstairs and the bed's a mess i
literally just feel like
it just really bothers me and it's not
relaxing a bedroom should be calm and
relaxing
all the time so yeah so i don't uncle
carmen relaxing yeah
sleeping on it yeah not looking after
you yeah i guess so i guess
but here's the thing right so i do have
afternoon naps
no no not even a nap i i like to work
comfortably sometimes i'll be rushing
around at that
and i'll be on zoo meetings but then if
i've got like half an hour i can just do
some admin
i don't i think i don't want to just sit
in the office and do admin i'm going to
go up to my bedroom have a little lie
down and just do some stuff on the
laptop half an hour or so
make a couple loose calls to some you
know like russell or whoever
maybe have a little nap but then
i will sometimes either not make the bed
at all
or make it but very badly
very badly probably not like it at all
really probably not make it it's just
it's just funny so mandy said i didn't
but i wasn't even was doing it
because in my mind i'm just thinking
well i don't know i wasn't even thinking
so then um but anyway the point
communication
yeah you didn't get upset about it no
you're going to mood about it you just
said to me
you know what um samuel it really
bothers me when you
mess the bed up can you kind of put it
at least half
back when you do it that would make me
feel much better so when we come up in
the evening
to the bedroom it looks just nice and i
was like oh and
but so so so that's communication yeah
but then in terms of putting the other
person first
i could have been thinking oh what's the
problem and argued about there to be
laid in type thing yeah but obviously
i'm saying that now but i'm kind of just
kidding around but in reality when you
said it well
you know i'm just like okay well that's
fine so ever since
now i make the bed yeah now i don't even
know when he's been in because it's
always just
that's how good i am so i think yeah so
i think lessons
um you know for for me i think yeah
putting into the business but also
communication
and in in business same story if you've
got if you're if a member of staff is
doing something that you've got a
problem with and i have this just last
week there's a member of staff
uh very senior that was doing something
that i wasn't happy with i wasn't
comfortable with
and i i said he didn't want nobody comes
with that
and i could have spoken to different
people about it and thought about it and
gone through the contracts and this
stuff the other and then
tried to lay the lord on but i didn't i
just picked up the phone and just went
oh i'm not actually super comfortable
with this you know can we have a
conversation
where are you at what do you think and
it was solved like within five minutes
they were like oh my bad i didn't see it
like that
and it was just fine there was no
conflict there was no disciplinary
meeting there was no
management managers having to come into
it i think sometimes just
quick communication in an in
a non-emotional way yeah you didn't say
to me i'm so annoyed about the bed oh no
it's just like oh hey is there any
chance that when you messed that up you
kind of put it back best you can
yeah because it makes me feel much
better that's communication combined
with putting the person first
i think that's the biggest lesson yeah
but i'm sure there's many
many more okay um brandon bentley says
what role does your wife play i guess
this is a question for me
in your business well it's not my
business it's our business
um also what was one of the first things
you bought when you became a millionaire
hmm okay so what what why what role does
my wife play in our business
um well you i guess you could you can
you can you you work on the development
side of the business
yes i do but you also i don't think
you've seen our first episode because we
actually talked about this in a bit more
detail
um but yes i work more on the
development side and also
managing and looking after our personal
portfolio as well
um so we've got two portfolios we've got
our personal property portfolio which is
all the properties that
i accumulated before we got married yeah
um and then also we
we continued shortly maybe a year or two
we did continue buying
uh but around about 2016 when the
tax changes and all that happened we
then
began investing differently so now we
have a development company where we buy
land and build houses and all that kind
of stuff you help with that
a bit you help ben and you work but
you're responsible for heading up the
personal portfolio
and um and also i i see i'm as a
business partner so so
to me if i'm having to make any decision
in the business if there's anything that
or where should we go what should we do
we discuss it together don't we so
you know mandy's like um um an
advisor of the board an advisor of the
board
what was one of the first things you
bought when you became a millionaire
well i became a millionaire aged 25
i can't the thing is when you become a
millionaire
it's not like you go from broke to
suddenly like boom you got a million
pounds in the bank
yeah it's more of a before you're a
millionaire
your net worth is going to be 950 000
right and then before that it'll be
900 000 and it happens a little slowly
so i've been in property for many years
before
i became a millionaire so what do you
think what was the very first thing you
bought
it would have won the lottery you know
that would be a different story but it
took years to become a millionaire
so i imagine we were millionaires when
we went to
california imagine we probably were by
that time yes
i think we were just after we got
married yeah so that's probably the
first
to be fair that was probably the first
really splash holiday
i bought i bought a range row i bought
the when i uh
it wasn't the big one i drive now but i
i i went from a
i literally went from adachia when i got
the range rover revoked which is not a
massively impressive car i think they're
worth about 50 grand
but for me i'd say that was probably
your first big yeah
it was yeah because before then i'd
always even when we got married
i'd always lived really below my means
so i had
a portfolio of lots of houses but i
lived very frugally
like when we first met i was living in
astray close in the turnberry yeah which
was
nicer area than i grew up in it was a
nice part of block switch but it was
just a two bed
terrace house yeah so you know i i was
financially free i had a portfolio of
quite a lot of houses
i was a property millionaire but i
wasn't a net millionaire
um so yeah we went and then i think it
was probably when i became a millionaire
to be fair when i was like right i'm
going to start
and we got married yeah i was you know
when we started spending a bit more
money i got a nicer car
you got an upgrade i did
i know it's now i bought you an audi
just before we got married yeah before
we were
anyway um or actually i say bought you
we released that um it's hard sometimes
i forget like my range rover now
i bought but sometimes i think i lease
it yeah because it doesn't matter
what's the difference you just have it
still yeah yeah
it's just something that you use you
know um so
so yeah california holiday we spent i
think 26 grand
yeah 26 grand on that holiday were there
for a month which is quite we stayed at
the beverly hills hotel and
so it wasn't ridiculous amount of money
to spend not like some of the more
recent one
it's a gradual thing it's hard to say
like 9 million and then i just bought
this
um best thing you've ever bought though
nicest thing oh
oh i don't know
yeah you like your bags i think i do
love bags but you've always got me bags
as a gift
yeah but yeah i probably say bags that's
what i've always okay
oh this is a tough one to answer oh
well for me anyway i don't know what you
all have to say if we're
watching you on youtube who
are you watching on youtube oh
okay i can answer this because i love i
watch youtube all the time come on
so i love um lydia dinger on youtube
she's amazing
yeah i also watch only bells yeah and
they just do like
lifestyle liddy dinger's recently done a
renovation on her property she bought
first property so i've been watching
that that's been good
yeah really good yeah those two um
yeah probably say they're my mainly my
most two watched
channels oh no who do i watch on youtube
oh man i don't really know you i don't
know what you what do you want
boring stuff yeah i watched like a lot
of debates
yeah like yeah debates political debate
like jordan peterson i watched jordan
peterson i watch
um oh man it's really hard it is hard
because i watch documentaries
go on yeah okay you watch sometimes you
watch pranks but that's like i do watch
prank videos i love
prank videos you like only pranks yeah
ernest pranks is so
funny yeah we love that too um oh jeez
what else do you watch that's so strange
actually i can't think but it's usually
just random videos that you watch
there's no like one channel that i watch
yeah religiously no there is
i like educational stuff um that's why i
like documentaries
um but yeah i'd have to have a thing wow
that is so hard that's quite funny i
watch quite a lot of tick tock videos as
well these days i like tic toc videos
but again
tick tock videos again like if i go on
his tick tock it's just all like
politics and just things like not
necessarily politics
like economics yeah economics like it's
so weird because
i'm like how is this tick tock because
it just doesn't seem like tick-tock
tick-tock is that people dancing people
cooking
his is totally different tomorrow it's
like a more mature version of
all right all right brandon
bentley oh we read that one already all
right james pierre
now what is your advice on gaining a
successful
mindset go ahead oh
i think you'd better you'd be best
answering this but
i'd probably say coming from a place of
abundance and not
constantly thinking like oh i'm broke or
oh i'm less than oh i can't do this
like just coming from a different space
so approaching things in a way that
you'll i was going to say attract i
don't want to say attract but
where are your can you think of what i'm
trying i think i think look look what
you focus on
expands yeah so in terms of successful
mindset how do you have a successful
mindset
um one of the things i'll say is you can
choose what you think about
you can choose what you think about and
and what you think about
then will make you feel a certain way
and
act in a certain way so how do you have
a successful mindset
probably by choosing to have positive
thoughts
to fill your to consume your mind with
positive stuff you know rather than
watching
trash on youtube you know like cooking
shows and you know dancing and stuff
like that
yeah you're so cheap there's a time in a
place
i'm just kidding that obviously isn't
trash but a lot of people watch trash
watch gossip on tv and you know the
latest celebrity who's got cellulite and
oh look at this dude
it's just that's just nonsense if you if
you start if you fill your mind with
that kind of stuff
you're not going to have a very
fulfilled successful life whereas if you
if you fill your mind with positive
stories and educational things
and focus on that i just think that's
probably the best way to get yourself in
a good mindset
and also who you hang around with yeah
so
if your friends or whoever are not of
that same and they're just like
different
different to what you want to be then i
probably wouldn't hang out with them
two more questions number one liam
barlow these are all from guys these
questions are all from guys
um will you send your kids to private
school
i imagine you will but there are many
many reasons as i'm aware you didn't go
to private school yourself ironically i
actually did go to private school myself
however there's a big however
it was not a private school that you
would potentially you would imagine as a
private school um
the reason it was private it was because
more a case of
my mom is a community christian but
we're also christians
um but she wanted me to go to she didn't
believe in some of the things that were
being taught in state schools so she put
me into a christian private school
um education wise
i mean i don't want to sound harsh but
you could easily argue that it was
probably
worse than a state school in terms of
like the quality of
the support the quality it was a bit
there was a lot of people in the school
that weren't that smart
i i was probably average at school and i
was really bad academically so
although it was private it wasn't what
you'd imagine when you think of a
private school where you know it's
really academic and
great and and whatnot um not to say it
was bad
it wasn't it wasn't bad but yeah it was
all right it was called emanuel
christian school in fact it still runs
today so you can check it out and you'll
see exactly what i'm talking about i
don't know if it's not changed wouldn't
we send out you went to private school
there i did i went
to a better private school than yeah so
i went to private school but this was in
zimbabwe
and it was really really good school
where i went um
the president's daughter actually went
to the same school so it was
a really good i would say probably
wilson like his departure school but to
be honest they're quite young at the
moment so it's not really something that
we've
made but also i think yeah where we live
there's also really good grammar schools
as well so
oh i don't really know i don't know yet
neither and i'm not really even thinking
about it right now we've just been
you know thinking about i guess us
no what i mean is like we we've moved to
the area we want to move to we've been
bringing our family down we've been
i've not really been thinking about too
much i'm uh but yeah i would want them
to have i would want them to go to a
good school for sure yeah i want them to
have a good time
and again would we send them to uni and
stuff well i don't think you send your
kids to uni
that's their decision what we would do
is we want to give our kids the best
education that we can
and then when they get to 16 then they
can choose do they want to stay on do
they want to go to uni
and it all depends on what they want to
achieve if they want to be a doctor or a
lawyer then they're going to have to go
to uni if they want to be an
entrepreneur
then it probably is a waste of time yeah
all right last question emmanuel
here are some questions how do you feel
about pets
i've never seen or heard any
reference to liking or having any
pets good observation all right pets um
well we almost got a dog
last year we did i wasn't
majorly you know for that idea
isn't bob white yeah in zimbabwe dogs
are just outside animals they're just
there as guard
dogs and animals like having a pet
outside the house so for me
having a pet inside the house is just a
no-no like no thanks
and if i ever did because i don't mind
dogs i had a dog growing up but it used
to sleep outside
but if i did ever get dog i'd want a
really cute small
dog remember what dog we almost got
a shep skip yeah german shepherd
crossbar skate they're really nice
because they look like a husky but
they're
like a guard dog as well like it like uh
um we do
have well what about nate i guess he's
technically not ours but he lives in one
of our houses
where my brother lives he's like a
massive man
he's so big yeah so but when he comes
around to our house normally he's
outside as a guard dog
um we i love dogs i love animals
we had a guard dog no a guide dog we
trained
me and my family before way before like
when i was a kid or a teenager
we trained a puppy called eddie and we
trained him to be a
guide dog for the blind um and he failed
he failed his his tests and stuff and
then they asked us if he wanted to keep
him we said yes
so we had him for about 10 years before
he passed away which is really sad
and we also trained other dogs that did
pass and became
uh guide dogs for the blind um so yeah i
really like dogs i would happily have a
dog
but i'm not really bothered either way
so if amanda's not comfortable
having a dog in the house yeah probably
a bit unless the dog
was a dog that was meant to be outdoors
i think it there's no point having a dog
it's just gonna be outdoors
also i just don't like the idea of
having to like walk a dog
picking up poop it's just not we've got
three kids so there's enough going on in
this household
um it's like having a kid that never
grows up i think that's the thing it's
like
with a with a child that's so harsh it
is i mean dogs are lovely i love i like
dogs but it is it's like having a kid
when you go on a holiday
you have to get a baby russell's got two
dogs so i guess we've
you know we we've got access we see it
we see them a lot
um although you tend to avoid avoiding
that's like so big
is massive um literally when he like
jumps up he's like
the same height as me also i like cats
so we've kind of
adopted a cat there's a little black cat
around the area always around he's
always around but
when i you know goes
into the house and give it some love
amanda's like oh yeah
especially cats sorry cat lovers oh man
if we were to ever get a pet it'd be a
dog but i don't think we will
yeah well that's that yeah so
if you've got questions no matter how
personal they are put them in the
comment below whether it's about money
marriage life albeit uh whatever so
mandy before we close i wanted to say
final words of wisdom i always forget
i always forget i don't think i have any
final words of wisdom today
other than just i guess focus on the
good focus on the good
yeah and what you focus on expands be
grateful
stay blessed stay tuned subscribe to the
channel
and soon one day if amanda has the time
she will actually turn this into a
podcast and upload it onto itunes and
spotify which
i'm sure will happen one day hey thanks
so much guys and we'll see you next time
thanks for watching bye